to kick off season 2 of the all-new
revamped relaunched refurbish rebranded
and rebooted Ruben Report there was
really only one person to sit in this
blue chair
my guest this week is a neuroscientist
and author whose views have been
described as gross and racist by Batman
himself Sam Harris welcome back to the
Rubin report thank you you know
congratulations on the new digs I like
this yeah
thank you well you sort of launched the
whole thing because I kind of wasn't
even planning on doing an interview show
right and we sat down and then I thought
maybe I'm my right at that so it led to
it led to something yeah well you're
great at it I mean that's what you look
like we've been talking offline about
why this has been so successful online
but it's just it's the only long-form
interview with a journalist who's not
pretending to not have an opinion right
everyone else is pretending and my thing
is that I don't feel I have to know
everything do you find as someone that
knows a lot of stuff do you feel
pressure to know everything and that
people want you to comment on every
little thing that happens
ah well it depends what this situation
is I feel pressure so on my own podcast
I often feel pressure to know enough
about the topic to be able to deal with
my guests in an intelligent way but the
real pressure is to be honest early
enough I mean let me just basically have
your full intellectual and ethical
commitment to be not to pretend to know
something yeah so that I mean that is
just the magic bullet in every situation
if you're pretending to know things you
don't know you are always vulnerable to
embarrassment if you're just and to not
you know I tend not to have strong
opinions about things I don't know a lot
about so whenever I really am inclined
to go to the mat on something I'm pretty
sure I understand what I'm arguing about
and so it's I can't remember the last
time I had a
a very strong opinion about something
where it turns out I was completely
uninformed and completely wrong and but
even then when that happens to most
people's reflex is the way to stay a
face here is to dig in the West a face
is to hold on more tenaciously to this
opinion which now is eroding in real
time in a conversation right and whereas
it's that's to lose face twice over I
mean there's nothing more attractive
really it's except you never see this
but there is nothing more attractive
than someone being intellectually honest
enough to notice that they're wrong as
close to the moment that the audience
does as possible and to then disavow
their their false certainty yeah I
remember not too long ago maybe three or
four months ago
you actually tweeted something
apologizing to Glenn Greenwald and he is
at least in my humble estimation said
really terrible things about you and and
really manipulated your words and
retweeted things that are not what you
really believed but I think you very
clearly did it and then you you followed
up with something to that effect that
you didn't bother you that I guess had
you was it saying that he said that you
miss quoted or something like that but
yeah well it turns out so I don't be too
quick to apologize the Glenn Greenwald
turns out baby then I know he's done it
again since with you but no but knowing
nobody a thing that I was apologizing
for it yet so he had someone had
forwarded an article that was fairly
disparaging of his journalism like me he
had formed some alliance with someone
who turned out to you know be fighting
for Isis you know this is a person who
had been on the no-fly list and Glenn
Greenwald you know multiple tweets and
in articles on the intercept had
defended him what an abomination
no remember and then some conservative
website had reviewed all this
journalistically instead they look who
look what happens but when you when you
defend a guy like this because now this
guy turns up in Turkey and he's under
arrest
he's an Isis sympathizer and many people
had sent this to me and I just read the
article it seemed like it made sense and
I forwarded it as
does when one is fighting back against
people like Glenn Greenwald yeah but
then Glenn defended himself on the
intercept he said that this is wrong in
all these ways and so I I mean again
this is also it's the bandwidth problem
you know if you don't have time to react
check everything you know right it's
just it's how would you fact check
everything so when Glenn offered some
defense of his journalism there I said
all right maybe I don't know what
happened and so I so I up up I deleted I
actually asked the advice of you know
the Twitterati you know how do you get
heavy clean up this mess
easy forward something do you just
delete it or do you link to it and
apologize and I forget what the
consensus was but anyway I apologized
publicly to him on Twitter for for
boarding it and then I think it came out
that actually he was guilty of almost
ninety percent of what was said in the
original article but you know I everyone
moves on there but I am I'm very
scrupulous about not misrepresenting the
views of my enemies and I use the word
enemy now really unselfconsciously it's
kind of a strange word to use yeah but I
mean it's obvious to me now that I have
people who are so malicious in their
intentions toward me that I can't think
of them as anything other than enemies
and but whenever I have made the mistake
of saying something that was however
inadvertently misleading about what
their positions are I've done my best to
correct it you know right and that goes
to what you say all the time about
intentions matter and that's why for me
I don't mind being wrong and I actually
like being corrected and I've had a
running joke for three years with Cara
Santa Maria who I think you know where
every time I would screw up something
scientific on the show I'd bring her on
a couple weeks later and then she would
correct me and I'd say look I'm not a
scientist I know the most that I can and
here's someone that's going to lay it
out night if that never struck me is
that brilliant what I was doing I
thought I was just being being honest so
I think that's sort of a good segue to
let's just go back to what we did when
we did that sit down because my
intention with that as I told you right
up top was let's just clean up some of
this mess some of them
you know you want a nuclear first strike
on the Muslim world and the profiling
all Muslims and all this stuff and we
chopped it into little YouTube clips and
I thought we did everything that that
could possibly be done to help clean up
this conversation and that when people
would misquote you or whatever was that
it would be an easy digestible form and
all that within two days of doing that
it all happened again one of one of your
quotes do you remember the Seinfeld
quote and what happened so we don't have
to get into the Nitty Gritty of it in
terms of you know because like Reza
retweeted it saying that you said people
who look like Jerry Seinfeld but that's
not what you say I said Jerry Seinfeld
the comedian shouldn't profile because
he's probably not a jihadist and it's a
waste of resources and all that stuff so
I don't want to get into the minutiae
but what what do you do with with that
like we're at I feel like we're at a
very odd place in discourse in America
where truth is completely subjective now
and people don't care no matter how many
times you expose these people yeah well
there is I think that's what's happened
that there's a tribalism to all of these
arguments and the side you're on for the
most part is not doesn't feel it all
ethically obligated to honestly interact
with the opposing side and so it's just
everything is a smear campaign you're
just trying rather than it's one thing
to spread accurate information shut out
the other side which is in your view the
destabilizing of their position if
you're criticizing them with accurate
information but so much of what we see
is just an ends justify the means
rationale where it's just they'll spread
anything that is libelous you know short
of exposing them to a lawsuit and that
the the difficulty for CAA and suing
someone for liable is just I mean the
bar is set so high that no one even
thinks about it yeah so that guy who
keeps calling us white supremacists
that's not that's not liable yet does
not once you're a public figure
basically because I mean think of what
can be said about Trump right now
without getting sued you can basically
say anything you want about Trump yeah
so but yes I mean even so even the Trump
is a great example I think you know
Trump is a truly dangerous person in
terms of the the fact that it's even
conceivable that he could be President
is a is not only a scandal it's a real
danger to this country but when I see
the way he's maligned by the left half
of it at least is dishonest yeah you
know and and that's that's a real
problem it's a problem for the left yeah
and we're gonna get into the left
because III mean do you feel the same
way I think I think you do but the
reason I focused on the left is because
I've always considered myself part of
the left I don't know to me at this
point I don't know that these labels are
all starting to change and I don't think
they matter that much anymore at this
point being liberal to me doesn't strike
me as a position of the left anymore
really being free radical thinking and
and an honest debate and and free speech
that's really not what's on the left
anymore and again that's not a defense
of the right that's what everyone will
suddenly say I see he's defending the
right yeah not defending the right I'm
just saying I don't know that I can be
part of this anymore Dee do you feel
similarly for that yeah if people talk
about classical liberalism now and yeah
to differentiate the liberalism from
what's happening on the left and yeah if
you are a liberal you have to be
committed to free speech a free speech
has to win just across the board and you
what we're seeing on the left is a kind
of sensoria sness and really kind of an
authoritarian moment where they're just
trying to stifle the expression of ideas
which however provocative are not
obviously false right so that the burden
is on you to interact with these
provocative ideas if you think they're
dangerous or just mistaken yeah and show
them to be dangerous and or mistaken and
and it's an interesting question are
their true ideas that are dangerous to
to talk about well then that's that's a
debate we can have maybe there's certain
facts that are not worth knowing but
would you say there are I mean I pretty
much would say that you can
absolutely say and think anything short
of the direct call for violence to to an
individual or group I think you have to
have someone but beyond that you want to
put out shoots cartoons out there all
day long and you want to put not see
this and that congratulations young
guy in your basement sending those
meetings do you think you're you're
great and that makes you big I just
think I would put no limitations other
than the director but do you think the
direct threat is even well I think there
should be no limitations on that kind of
speech because say like the Holocaust
denial laws in Europe I think are absurd
and counterproductive but no I wasn't I
was thinking of actual knowledge that
one could have or seek that is just not
worth having and whether it's you know
you know putting the the formula to
weaponized smallpox online right so like
we we know how to do this and you know
why should we advertise our knowledge
and and why should we even seek this
knowledge on some level hmm or in
certain kinds of research where it's
like do you want do you actually want to
put money into looking for intelligence
differences among races and different
populations like what's the point do we
want to do we actually want to quantify
the average intelligence of Japanese
people versus Korean people you know
what we're just going to come to that
yet right
and so yeah certain I think there's
certain facts that they're not worth
getting yeah what you're saying they're
not worth getting but you're not saying
people can't go be free to go ahead and
no you're saying it would be a fruitless
effort or you know wouldn't have much
philosophical worth or something like
yeah but it also it could be socially
harmful to make much of those facts no
it is so again if there's a gene for
materialism you know it just you know
acquisitiveness right you and some
scientists says listen what I want to
spend a million dollars on is to figure
out if Jews have this gene more than
then the right well it's gay
but I guess like a lot easier is there a
gene for Jewish you know hoarding right
like is that the scientific paper you
want to try to write right you would
have to question the social motives of
somebody who knew that and obviously
there's you know analogous things you
would do in the black community or in
any other community yeah and so I think
it would be very very easy to stigmatize
that research and and there's maybe a
reason to avoid it because it's just
there's nothing you're going to do with
the information that is at all socially
positive but that doesn't mean it's it's
not a possible thesis right and so if
someone said listen I've you know I've
genotyped
400,000 Jewish people and it turns out
we'd you know we have this gene for
acquisitiveness and it's it's shown it's
kind of upregulated in among hoarders
and and people who you know become very
wealthy but won't spend any of their
money like famous misers we've done all
this and turns out you know Ashkenazi
Jews have this much more than other
people let's talk about it that person's
career would be destroyed right or his
bigotry but that would be it so it's
totally rational thing we could talk
about and as a Jew I wouldn't be the
least defended by the the entertaining
that fact and I'd be interested in the
science and I I just think it's trying
to make you a Jew a folk just by saying
that because I can see the memes flying
are you gonna but to be you can imagine
some of the the the parent interest that
people would have in that kind of
research it would attract people who
were interested in it for the wrong
reasons and you know so every
anti-semite in the world would want to
you know to want that to be true right
yeah
and as same so it is with Intel you know
IQ differences were among blacks and
whites and Asians and I mean that's you
know all that research is so heavily
stigmatized and one wonder is what's the
point of doing it because what are you
going to do differently as a result of
getting and getting those data but it
doesn't mean that it's synonymous with
bigotry to actually understand the you
know genetic differences there and right
now we have with Eve
and then there's an endless amount of
this stuff coming to us in the future I
mean more and more we're going to be
deluge with information that that
becomes increasingly actionable right I
mean where we can decide to change our
own genomes or the genomes of our kids
and yeah then it's all it then all of
this very inflammatory these very
inflammatory areas of where people are
they're basically no-go areas in science
now they're going to open up in
surprising ways because we're going to
be forced to we'll just we'll have
choices to make do you know how
intelligent do you want the next
generation to be if we have a trivial
trivially easy intervention that allows
us to add 30 IQ points to the next
generation with no basically no downside
I mean once we understand the the
genetics of intelligence there there
will be massive resistance tube that
will be a taboo thing to do and yet you
have to have an argument for maintaining
that taboo right or maintaining the
status quo you have to have some
argument as to why the status quo is
normative that why it's why it's good
why you because if I said well there's a
there's a neurotoxin has fallen from
space and actually destroyed the brains
of everyone exposed to it and now the
next generation if we do nothing the
next generation is going to be 30 points
dumber than we are right but we have
this intervention should we bring it
back should we bring the status quo back
well everyone would be for that right so
it's just a anyway these are these even
talking about intelligence is so fraud
is socially and ethically then it's
people avoid it and almost any cause so
in a way it would be like that at least
for people that come at this from a
religious angle they don't want to play
God so that they wouldn't I would
imagine if this appeared and we could
get everyone's IQ up 30 points that it
would be the religious people who would
say don't do this primarily not not
solely but it would be a lot
these people because they wouldn't want
us to play God but yet if it happened
the other way as you laid out everyone
would basically be for it so it sort of
just depends which way we come at these
things right yeah well it's kind of as
an anchoring phenomenon we're anchored
to the status quo there's a dosa called
a status quo bias that that people are
just heavily predisposed to think that
what is normally the case is somehow
good and you change it at your peril but
things many things are the way they are
by dint of accident or what in hindsight
would look like bad luck and so the
question is what good things would come
of making changes and more and more I
mean what technology is above anything
else is an agent of changing the status
quo you know for thousands of years in
in human history or you know millions of
years in human history at a minimum
hundreds of thousands of years you could
take blocks of thousands of years and
you know if you were born at the
beginning of the end there was basically
no difference there was no change they
were there working with the same toolkit
you had the same arrowheads and stone
axes and and even until very recently
the from generation of generation the
the human circumstance was pretty
recognizable if you were you know on a
hundred years on either side of any
moment and but more and more everything
is up for revision and that's that's a
myth obviously there are obvious risks
associated with that because we don't
necessarily understand the implications
of what making the changes we're making
that do you think that will become
accelerated as time goes on because of
where we're at with technology you know
like my parents didn't have you know
television wasn't out until they were
about eight and now it's like I see my
four-year-old nephew with an iPhone and
you know my niece was two playing on the
iPad before she can speak you know like
all this stuff you think we get to a
point where the technology keeps
slamming us and yet we're not ready to
figure out what this actually all means
you know
something as simple as just putting a
kid in front of a screen when they're to
your and having them think that that's
actually a real fish tank not the fish
tank on the on the counter yeah well I
think it is accelerating there's no
question its accelerating and the my the
migration of culture into digital space
is only enabling that because obviously
you can change the cloud more quickly
than you can change the world and and so
it's it's a insofar as culture is
becoming more and more a matter of
information I think I think that is
compounding the acceleration but the
acceleration was what's happening anyway
yeah all right before we get too far
down down all this stuff let's just wrap
up some some Islam stuff which I assume
that if we discuss right now we could
pretty much put a bow on it and we'll be
good we'll be good to go right everybody
slander nothing will be slandered I know
there's people probably watching this
right now some of these you know missing
tension that best people watching is
just waiting for the moment right there
just sitting can you imagine being one
of those people just sitting there going
I can get one word out of him if I can
just if you could just say this this way
hi it's I I'm you were talking about
playing catch-up to technology I feel
like I'm perpetually playing catch-up to
this sort of ethical surprise that
people do this because III it's very
hard for me to imagine being this way on
purpose but much of this is really done
so relentlessly that I know it's not a
matter of you know accident or they just
couldn't watch the whole video or you
know because it's um I feel like I'm
pretty charitable to the the people who
do this by mistake I mean like this like
they just can't they heard something
said about my view mmm-hmm and they
think well that's got to be true it was
said by a journalist or I appeared in
Salon Miss Alonso real magazine right so
they're you know how how could this be
completely fabricated I actually am a
free speech absolutist except for so on
yeah that's right that's the one but
they've made me quite sympathetic to
Donald Trump's effort
and everything right but he but I mean
it is just the case that people actually
do this maliciously and it's it's we
have to be on our guard for it and I'm
very when I see something like again
Donald Trump's a perfect example cuz
he's someone who you almost cannot
malign enough right now so worthy of
being buried in scorn and I mean it's
just the immune system of civilization
has to fully encase him and just and
export him from from our political
process and then forget about him but
when I see some of the stuff that's done
to him it's completely without an
ethical core yeah right well this is
just ends justify the means right
they're looking at him and going he's as
evil as as you would lay out and
probably will lay out so they say all
right well our ethics and our standards
are now out the window because we just
want to destroy this guy which is a
scary place for journalists to be in
yeah much less the average person yeah
all right but that's that's a good segue
yeah you wanted to take us back well
just quickly designed with anyone full
topic so the joyful topic of Islam
because that that will then get us to
trump it's hit me that since I've sort
of been in this conversation and again I
wasn't really in it that much until we
launched that show on order back in
September that the biggest issue here
forgetting the people that with bad
intentions but the biggest for the for
the majority of people that are trying
to get some truth out of this people
simply cannot separate the religion from
the political ambitions of Islam now I
know you've laid this out on you you
talked about the pupils and what
Islamism is versus jihadism and the
nominal Muslim and all that have you in
all of this conversation gotten to a
place where you think you have a better
handle maybe now than you did six months
ago or a year ago on how to address that
because to me the the religion part the
set you say Islam people assume religion
and then then automatically even if you
a thousand times over say I'm talking
about a doctrine not the people who
practice it however they may
automatically people get upset
by that versus somehow focusing more on
the political part which that's the part
that I fear more I don't care what
anyone does in their private life as
long as it's not trying to behead me or
something like that have you figured out
any way to negotiate that any better or
is that even something that you think
about do you think it's a wasted
exercise or or any of that well it's not
wasted it's just it's the signs of one
success are not necessarily obvious but
I think it's it I mean it's just the
case that people have certain
assumptions about religion in general
and Islam in particular that are not
true and the only remedy is to push on
those assumptions and show them to be
false and so be the one that's most
common which I have been talking about
for years but I haven't found a better
way to address it which is just the
assumption that all religions are
basically the same is false right it's
just that their their vast differences
among the religions and these are
differences that the adherents of the
religions really care about right now if
a devout Muslims care that their
religion teaches something different
from Mormonism right that's the whole
point yeah it's like all it fit all the
details matter and the crazier you are
the more attached you are to the
doctrine they matter more and so and
given that there are these differences
among religions we are actually misled
when we just use the word religion over
and over again to describe what people
are doing and and why they're doing it
and so yet to separate the political
piece of Islam it from the religion is
more difficult because the religion
doesn't do that it doesn't do a good
yeah and if it well intentioned for the
most part it doesn't do it at all you
know reformers are trying to do this
like someone like Majid Nawaz you've had
on the show yeah is trying to do this
but it is there really is a dogma within
the faith which says this can't be done
and shouldn't be done this is
a Islam is a total system for living
your life and it includes the politics
and it includes the laws that govern you
know how you treat homosexuals and
infidels and women and all that and so
it is a it is a modernizing reformist
project to dissect out the real quote
religious spiritual otherworldly stuff
and the ethics say from any kind of
political commitment to to making sure
your society conforms to to Islam and so
which is the the Islamist project and so
yes I think it's useful is so someone
like moderate who talks about Islam on
the one hand and Islamism on the other I
think that's very useful and I've
adopted that you know under his you know
on the basis of his argument and but the
thing we can't lose sight of is is just
what a still steep hill that is to climb
in view of most Muslims because when the
most the most dispiriting thing I've
encountered since my collaboration with
Majin and we had we as probably most of
your viewers know we we wrote this book
together we were initially adversaries
in a way and I reached out to him and
decided to just see if we could do a
kind of a blog exchange and it became so
fruitful we did this book together and
maje it as you know is just impeccable
and as reasonable and ethical and wise
as anyone you're going to find on this
topic I mean he's just like you couldn't
invent a better spokesman for a rational
secular reformist Muslim project like
like just the it he's he's basically
perfect and yet to see the degree to
which he has been hated by this
so-called moderate Muslim community and
disavowed and his collaboration with me
viewed as just a total deal I mean the
this is this is the amazing thing is
he's actually said by one point our
collaboration he said you know my
into you a well-known atheist and critic
of Islam is is far more controversial
than my talking to a jihadist yeah
like literally he literally could to
have done a book with with Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi in a head of Isis yeah like
let's get this straight there's the
reformist project and then there's the
you know true jihad project let's talk
about it right you know that would be
initiating book but but that would be
less controversial among so-called
moderate Muslims yeah and his talk into
a a well-known atheist that's you know
that is like a just an x-ray view of
virtually everything that's wrong with
the Muslim community at the government
and the burden is upon Muslims to talk
honestly about this right but they're
not helped by the people that should be
helping them on the left as we know and
then someone like so someone like Majid
who I agree with everything you just
said I mean I have incredible empathy
and sympathy and admiration for him
he so he gets hate from you know sort of
the mainstream Muslim community because
they don't want him talking about this
stuff then he gets treated horribly by
the left when they call him a lap dog
and all the other horrible things
they've said about him and then his only
way to talk about it is he has to either
talk to you who have become a lightning
rod for I think all the wrong reasons or
he has to go on Fox or something and
then there guys see he's a right winger
so it all becomes like this crazy mess
we're actually the left is is enabling
people they're they're pushing people
like Majid right I'm not saying any of
these positions are right but the only
outlets that young can let himself be
heard on end up being something like Fox
and that's crazy and I get messages all
the time my mom is ma Jude's biggest fan
every time she sees him on TV she calls
me yeah that that guy like we're we're
more of him like she loves everything he
says and yet it can pretty much only be
heard on Fox at least here in America
goes on CA well he's been done he's on
CNN and I've been with him on I think
MSNBC and CNN but he's yeah there
there's a
EMAS Frank it frankly is terrifying how
morally blind the left and the quote
moderate Muslim community is to just how
much obvious wisdom and ran risk he's
he's incurring I mean he's just he's
taking massive risks to try to find
daylight you know in this morass and
there really is only one path to that
daylight which is to talk honestly about
why there's so much mayhem in the Muslim
world mostly in the Muslim world I mean
but much of it obviously is being
exported to the non-muslim world and
that's what you know non-muslims tend to
worry about but you people like myself
and maje it and I on her CLE anyone
who's been talking about this for years
but we always admit that the the people
who are suffering most under Islamism
and jihadism are Muslims really that the
you know I don't actually know that the
current numbers but the vast majority of
people killed by jihadist terrorism are
Muslims right so liberals above anyone
should be concerned about coming to the
aid of these people who are being
reliably miserabie the chaos in the
Muslim world and then when you see how
this chaos gets exported to the migrant
crisis in Europe now and the way those
tensions are empowering the far right
and actually breaking Europe you know
how much of a brexit is due to the
migrant crisis I don't know but this is
not right a huge present out of it yeah
and so you look at it just because the
knock-on effects of all of this and
again the way in which it reliably
empowers people like Trump and and worse
and liberals and moderate Muslims want
to attack module and me when this
conversation starts happening right I
mean that they have endless energy to
attack the people who are just worrying
out loud about where this is all headed
it's obviously headed Wirth it's been
obvious for decades so it's well I see
these clowns and I'm always like if you
guys
could spend 15% of the anger and the
blame that you lay at the hands of Sam
every time someone else another jihadist
kills somebody just give them give them
15% of the anger you're directing to
this guy or or demage it or to Douglas
or you know a few of these other people
that would just be a little something so
yeah I don't want to focus on this too
much I know when I when I emailed you
before this you said let's talk about
anything so so that's what I intend to
do but how much just purely on the
personal level for you on the most
personal level how exhausted are you by
this topic you know I read we'll get to
waking up in a little bit really nothing
about Islam or jihadism I mean I know
that you're I think I know you well
enough to know that you're your real
sort of quest in life are the things in
that book to find that space as a human
and and be present and decent and all
those things and yet you've been not
only caught up in something that that's
so psychotic for so many reasons but
you've become the poster boy for it
right how just on the most personal
level how is that free for your spirit
or whatever you want to call yeah well
its it is toxic there's no question
about it I mean it being having to
respond or having to think about whether
or not to respond to a publicly
prominent attack on oneself which is
totally false right and in many cases
doesn't even admit of a response that
will be at all helpful innocent oh you
know it's the you know wrestle with pigs
principle which is in fact true you know
so how many times do you want to say
publicly in whatever way you can that
you're not a racist right when someone
is just condemned you know next week say
well no actually you're a racist so it
is toxic to do that and you just at a
certain point just have to hope that the
people who are paying attention who
actually care are going to notice and
they're going to be able to follow the
plot but there's been the campaign
against me in particular a few other
people like this and ayaan Hirsi Ali ah
certainly gets it worse
but the campaign against people the
prominent critics of Islam
is so well subscribed and so just shorn
of any kind of intellectual or ethical
conscience you know it is just these
it's like you suddenly attract to
yourself the attention of it just in a
kind of an army of sociopaths who just
have a lot of time on their hands
and just just going to get into every
comment thread and then some of them are
quote journalists you know who again
have no journalistic conscience yeah
that word that's really losing meaning
to journalists that yeah yeah but
there's this pretense of a commitment to
getting the facts straight but yet these
people never apologize when they get
facts wrong yeah and you know
egregiously wrong and to people like you
know Greenwald and jancker certainly in
that category so it is it is toxic but
at a certain point you just have to step
away from it and move on to other things
yeah so which is which I which I do
intermittently I'm sorry I step away
from it and then I get pulled back and
then it's sort of like the Mafia that
they answer I sort of sense I'm getting
for you it's like the Mafia like you try
to get out but they pull you back in and
then you just kind of go from there all
right so let's let's put that aside for
the most part and do some politics but
obviously those are those are linked
somewhat because Bill Maher who you know
how much I admire him he did a piece on
a show about a month ago saying that
Trump was not a creation of the left
this is solely on the right and actually
in as the over-the-shoulder graphics he
was showing articles saying that it was
a creation of the left and in one and
one of the articles was a piece by
Douglas Mari and he said and in the
piece you couldn't really read it over
shoulder he was small but I had read the
piece and it said something about how
Sam Harris the Bill Maher and Dave Rubin
are the only three liberals talking
about this I've been on the show yet but
I thought that I don't even know a few
times pretty good for me but this is one
thing where I actually even though bill
I think obviously has been incredibly
outspoken about Islam from the left so I
admire him I think he totally missed the
mark on this one because you've been
talking about this for a while I've been
talking about this almost the duration
of this whole show that if the left
won't deal with this honestly
it causes Trump to rise
and he really didn't quite follow that I
don't know if you saw that or not yeah I
don't think I saw it I heard that he
said it it'd be interesting to watch it
and see what his emphasis was cuz I
could imagine him emphasizing not
actually talking about the causality but
just talking about the the moral blame
the onus being on the right I guess it
is because ultimately there yeah there
you guys are responsible for this
monster you know this is the Republican
platform and your appear covert appeal
to races for generations and this is on
you this is a sign of all the
dysfunction on the right you've you've
dumbed it down so much among your base
mmm-hmm
that net you you've you've so you know
with you know being explicitly anti
science you know with climate change and
evolution and just pandering to
religious demagogues that you've now you
now have a base that is totally
unequipped to fact-check anything right
so so then you can just get a con man up
there who can who can promise he's going
to take us all to mars on a golden plane
and people believe him right and so i I
think he could have been saying that
that the just the onus is on the right
but if he was in fact saying that
there's not a causal connection between
how out to lunch the left has been on
these core you know civilizational
issues like what to do about global
jihadism right and the and the role that
religious ideas are playing and
inspiring it if he was denying that then
he I think he's yeah that way I think it
was I think it was the former and I I
don't want you have to comment it's too
far I didn't see it but I just thought
it was interesting because I thought
well here's someone who's really led the
charge and even before you were really
in it publicly I think he was he was
still talking about it and now I think
he's really missing a key piece to it
but hopefully I'll be able to discuss it
with him well no they don't point I can
feel it in myself I mean the reason why
in the laboratory of my own mind I can
see this working so if I didn't know
enough about how wrong Trump was on the
issues of policy I mean so far as he has
any beliefs about policy right but if I
wasn't paying attention
as much as I am - just how crazy the
implications are for his statements
about the economy and and building a
wall and deporting 12 million illegal
aliens and all the rest and I just had
and I was just concerned about terrorism
and then I saw Clinton and Obama not
making any sense in the aftermath of
something like Orlando yeah I can't say
jihadism never mentioning Islam yeah and
then defending that obscurantism with
this just sanctimonious and bullying
speech that and then I'm thinking about
Obama's speech once he was pushing back
against the pressure he was getting to
use the word radical Islam mm-hmm the
phrase radical Islam if I just had had
that to go on well then I I could see
how you would vote for Trump right you
just you got a guy who's at least naming
the problem yeah right and you know if I
didn't see what was wrong with the let's
keep all Muslims out of the country
right I'm not I don't see how
impractical and needlessly inflammatory
that policy prescription is and I just
see you know hoards of people streaming
into Europe unvetted and I see Britain
breaking off you know partially in
response and I don't see any liberal
politician who will even admit that
Europe has a problem yeah right there's
you know women are being raped and
groped in Copenhagen and the stories are
being buried and yeah you know it's it's
but all civilization is equal saying
yeah but it is like the emulation of a
civilization right right and and yet we
have it's taboo to talk about it so you
can see the appeal of like Trump saying
like lilia clue you see what's happening
in Belgium and and Germany that's not
going to happen here right that's that
appeal it
Hillary Clinton has to be able to say
that right she has to be able to
acknowledge that what's going on in
Europe is not perfect that Belgium has a
problem right and it's a problem of
having now millions of people
in their society however they got their
who actually don't have an interest in
sharing the values of the society the
liberal values of society and no one on
earth should be more concerned about
this than liberal liberals and actually
liberal Muslims who want to embrace
liberal values these are that those are
the people who should be all over this
problem right this is like the we're so
tolerant that we're tolerant of
intolerance and thus we will let people
who would yell Adly kill us right out of
the house yeah
and they're so at the margins there's
there's some room for that as what we
you know what we said about free speech
in the beginning and you know I do I
think you should criminalize certain
kinds of Islamist or jihadis speech no I
don't I think you should you know
someone like Anjem Choudary you know the
the Islamist buffoon of the UK yeah I
think he should be able to say whatever
he wants right and we should be able to
criticize the stupidity and divisive
misses and views so blasphemy laws of
any kind or not appropriate I mean
that's not how you fight this but so
there is it there is a kind of you know
our open societies have to be somewhat
tolerant with just excruciating ly bad
ideas which are which target the the
openness of the society itself and
cynically exploit it and you know I'm
going to you know say it's like the it's
like the KKK showing up in in the middle
of a black neighborhood knowing they're
going to be protected by the cops right
right
and then just talking about you know
saying all these things would put them
at just intolerable risk but for the
fact that the cops and we're protecting
them you so I think we have we more or
less have that right in our society so
but it's a it's a real problem that that
you know III think given a sufficiently
large terrorist attack closer to the
election unless Hillary Clinton can
actually make sense on this issue and
not just be a pure
guarantors I think it's is conceivable
that Trump still could get in is giving
Isis a vote in the election I think so
too and I don't think she's going to do
it short of something truly horrific
that then creates such a populist thing
even on the left I don't think she's
gonna get there and I sense that you're
sort of somewhat grudgingly supporting
her sort of that we just don't have
anyone better kinda I mean I think my
see my thing with Trump is that I get
and I went with Miley innopolis to UCLA
and and it was ineffective as a trump
rally because all the Trump people love
Milo and we just did a talk like we do
this and all these kids were coming up
to me after a smart UCLA kids of every
walk of life gay straight agent whatever
black anything it was and they were all
come up to me after and saying you know
I'm liberal but I'm supporting Trump
because of the free speech thing yeah
and I tried to explain to them that if
you think this is the guy who's
ultimately going to save free speech
that's kind of nuts because he's always
threatening to sue reporters and all
those other stuff but the sense that I
got from them and again these are young
college bright college kids was that
they don't care about any of the issues
right now they've grown up in a time
where they think government is so broken
and that all of them lie trump happens
to be lying a little more brazenly or a
little more the way a regular person
would lie as opposed to the way Hillary
would lie by tactically knowing each
word you know and Trump just does it in
a more common man way that they feel
this this cultural thing about free
speech and being able to say what you
want and and openly talk about Islamism
or immigration or or whatever it may be
they're voting on that and these were
liberals coming up to me and that's
where the first time that I thought now
I at least understand this and I have a
lot of my audience on it feels that way
and I it but it's a shitty way to have
to vote I think would you say that's
fair to say and then for me the irony is
that it would be so easy for Hillary to
yeah to just clean up her side of the
mess at least to the point where it
would nullify this argument or this and
this difference
her and him and I don't quite understand
at this point why she wouldn't do it
whose vote is she worried about losing
you know she's not it's not like there's
going to be an exodus of people who hate
Trump - Trump if she becomes more plain
spoken on these issues all right I guess
it's the it's the real sotius social
justice people that have been following
Bernie this whole time she's gonna have
trouble getting a certain amount of
young ones anyway
you know and she thinks if she uses any
of this language even though it would I
think in effect be smart and at least
more honest I think she feels she would
lose those people yeah I think I mean
she you know the Clintons I bought both
of them have their problems obviously so
it's it's it's hard to imagine how she
would fully rehabilitate her image in
the eyes of those who see her as a just
a kind of political robot who just wants
to be President and has wanted to be
President forever and they just want
power and influence and they're
dishonest and opportunistic to a point
where they're just this you know they
seemed scarcely human in a way and I and
when you look at the details of the end
of the funding of the Clinton Foundation
half of what Trump people say and
Sanders people say about the Clintons
seems to be true you know and and and so
it's you can't be idealistic about how
the sausage has gotten made on their
side you know in their careers but on
these on the issues that that I care
about the reason why I was specific I
can support her without much fear is
that I think 90% of the time
get you know even if the way she got
there is not ideal even if you know
she's been influenced by but banks and
whoever else that you may be will be
worried have too much influence on the
on the political process ninety percent
of time I think the policies she would
want to enact our policies that I would
support right so and even on the even on
the kind of Clash of Civilizations front
I think she is I think she understands
that we're not fighting the Amish and
we're not fighting
just and we're not fighting the Mormons
and when we talk about terrorism
generically we're not really sort of
thinking about the IRA also right where
we know we have a a global jihadist
insurgency that is coming from one
religion in one region of the world it's
now spread all over the world in terms
of the the contagiousness of the ideas
and and it's a it's a generational
battle to figure out how to empower the
moderate voices in the Muslim world I
think she must understand that despite
the fact that 90 percent of what she
says doesn't give any indication that
she understands that no indication yes
so do you think that she would probably
govern a little more with that
understanding that this is a little bit
of a nod just to keep the the left happy
yeah maybe costing her ultimately well I
think she's actually you when you talk
about jihadis she's as hawkish as anyone
you know which is it was just wipe a lot
of Sanders people haters right she's too
committed to the drone program for
instance and she's probably more hawkish
than Obama has been and he's basically
Dick Cheney if you're on the left now
right so um but I it still is important
how we talk about these things and they
obviously think it's important because
they're loath to use any honest
terminology to talk about these things
they think it's so combustible that if
you call a spade a spade you're going to
basically win the war of ideas for Isis
right which is it but we should just be
clear about what that is actually
suggesting it's saying that there are
some significant number of people a
non-trivial number of people in the
Muslim community who and whether they're
thinking this is tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands or tens of
millions I don't know but not certainly
enough to worry about who are just
doctors and dentists and coaching Little
League and they just they want to they
want to live the American dream or the
European dream as much as anyone these
are people who are never going to do
anything bad to anyone but if you
talk about this problem in a
sufficiently polarizing way right you
met and in particular if you admit that
there's a link between Islamism and
jihadism and specific doctrines within
the religion of Islam right so there's a
religious motivation to this extremist
behavior mm-hmm
if you admit that you are going to drive
these peaceful honest trustworthy people
into the arms of the theocrats these are
people who are actually going to go
fight with Isis or they're going to
quote self radicalize and start you know
killing people at their office parties
or they're going to fund people who do
or look the other way when their cousin
does it they're not going to and they
did they won't call the FBI knowing that
their cousin is going to go off and kill
a dozen people with his ar-15 that's
what they're worried about that's what
they're saying they're worried about so
that that really is the soft bigotry of
low expectations right because they're
saying these people are on such a
tenuous thread really oh yeah but if you
just say this you've coded it for them
and then here this comes so that that's
why it's such virtue signaling with me
to for the left it's like in a lot of
ways you are the the racist ones and you
know I don't want to throw that word out
like that but in a lot of ways you're
looking at it through the through the
lens of the way a race the way you would
purport everyone else to be racist yeah
you're viewing it that way yeah I mean
these are people are as you said so
precariously tethered to civilization
and it's commitments that one wrong word
and that just the mask comes off and
you're in the presence of barbarians
right and and this is a point that ayaan
Hirsi LA and her Celia is made for years
you in and over and over again in
response to the Danish cartoon
controversy she was pointing out that
you know that the very same ministers in
Western Europe who are condemning the
cartoonists and condemning the the
papers for printing these cartoons we're
busy you know locking up their embassies
and removing their staff because in
preparation for the barbarian onslaught
that they knew was coming right and
there's an meanwhile they're saying that
the Islam is a peaceful religion and
been unfair unfairly disparaged by these
cartoonist so it's a yeah it's either in
the in this guy I call it the narrative
narrative because people often say you
want to confirm the narrative of Isis if
we if we call this radical Islam we're
confirming the narrative of Isis or
jihadis generally that this is a war
between between the west and Islam and
so but the narrative narratives is
either the most uncharitable and and
paranoid thing ever said about a
community right or it's true now if it's
the former we should stop doing it it's
an awful thing to assume that you're
Muslim ob-gyn is this close to just
going berserk and or supporting those
who are going but just imagine what it
would take for you to suddenly support
an organization like Isis that is not by
virtue of collateral damage not by
accident but is intentionally cutting
the heads off of journalists and aid
workers and burning them alive in cages
and I've been crucifying children I mean
that's what they're doing again not
because of some failure of their
technology right or like the guy they
had bad information and they
accidentally bombed medicine some
frontier or somebody you know as we did
in Afghanistan yeah no this is this is
II you know with the with the by the
blade of a knife you know they do do
these things with a full ideological
commitment this isn't the end more than
that they export the the documentary
evidence of their doing it as propaganda
I mean this is this is their PR so
that's another thing that that people
don't really focus on the worst things
that people have ever done right are
tend to be the things that we're we hide
you know and are embarrassed by even if
we're basically committed to the cause
that required it to be done so for
examine the Nazis hid ouch wits from
themselves yeah right they hid so
there's a bit a with
culture just stocked with anti-semites
right I mean the level of an endemic
anti-semitism in in Germany at the time
and in Europe it generally was enough to
allow for the Holocaust but they still
had to censor this behavior from
themselves right and when you look at
behavior like the My Lai massacre right
so this is a the excess of American
militarism
you know the pathology is just it just
because it became a you know these are
soldiers just push to the breaking point
for whatever reason acting out and doing
some of the worst things that people
have ever done and this is a we we we
both conceal it and then once we can no
longer conceal it we atone for it it's
just this is something we cannot support
Isis is showing us the worst showing the
world the worst things they can possibly
do and that is what is so attractive to
the community that is of just imagine
this is like imagine the Nazis being
able to to show the full process of what
it's like in Auschwitz right like here
we separate them at the ramp and the
women and children just go straight into
the gas chamber and this is like be of
footage right and the piles of hair and
clothing and the bodies burning in pits
and imagine just put a fully
professional production they're putting
that on line and having the tens of
thousands of foreign recruits come in
because that just looks so damn good
right that is that the pathology of
ideas we're talking about and it's a it
is a a terrifying possibility which i
think is in fact sincerely worried about
by people like President Obama and
Hillary Clinton yeah that but you would
say the circle yeah that if you actually
acknowledged that there was a religious
link here right then some number of more
people would jump on the side of the
religion it's like well if you're going
to ask me to choose between Islam
the as it was practiced in the seventh
century and your Western values that
don't really support burning people
alive in cages and throwing gays from
rooftops and all that well I'm going to
have to go with Islam yeah it doesn't
matter that you know I got to be in
Orange County in 15 minutes to to take
my kid to a movie right right it's Jay
you know how many people like that
existed certainly some but I think it's
it's the reason why it's bad not to talk
honestly about the link to religion is
because it our denial of that link puts
absolutely no pressure
on the Muslim community to get its act
together I mean the only only Muslims
can solve this problem you know I can't
solve this problem obviously I'm just
this crazy infidel apasa if it'll a
theist who who just doesn't you doesn't
understand Islam doesn't it you know
it's just that why would anyone take me
seriously ah yeah right meanwhile I know
several things that you've done behind
the scenes to help a lot of free
thinkers in these places and yeah yeah
you don't run around screaming that kind
of thing and and no but I mean just
really it's it's easy to see how I would
have anything I say about Islam
critically or not or just linking
specific doctrines to specific behaviors
from the point of view of a Muslim
however devout it's just I'm the wrong
spokesman for that project hmm but the
problem is even Majin Mudge apparently
is the wrong spokesman right if former
Islamists who can say I know why I did
it I know why my friends did it now I'm
out let's talk honestly about the
problem and the link between specific
doctrines and the problem you know I on
is the wrong person you know I on born
into it knows exactly what it was like
to live in a theocracy God out of it has
been the victim of a theocratic
witch-hunt and it's you know liberal
enablers for now decades
she's got no standing and just do so and
then the people who do have standing the
people who are put forward as moderates
are
well almost without exception
obscurantists and liars and or closeted
Islam exist right here I mean that's a
so who you know when you look at what
their commitments are there you know in
bed with the Muslim Brotherhood or
they're just or they have absolutely no
moral core you've got someone like you
know Reza Aslan or or Dean Obeidallah or
someone who's just and I don't know what
they either them actually believe but
what they say is just pure denialism
about the the problems the and need for
reform with the Islam well I saw one of
them tweet after the what happened in or
Lunetta know in Mecca it was in May a
couple weeks ago right as a Mecca right
yeah and and one of them tweeted
something like well you see there
they're killing all these Muslims now so
that shows you can't be about religion
it's like actually this has been going
on forever as you said an hour ago
they've been killing more Muslims than
anyone else that doesn't mean it has
nothing to do with religion that shows
you there are divisions within religion
so it's this constant shell game that
they're playing that never allows for
truth yeah then you hear from Ahmadi
Muslims who who I mean sorry I get hate
from ADIZ who are a officially
blasphemers within Pakistan right
they're the sub group or they consider
themselves Muslims but they have a
founder who they consider also a prophet
and so they're just anathematized and
regularly killed in a place like
Pakistan but rather than point out just
how embattled they are and how and what
that says about Sunni Islam in general
right they'll attack me as someone who
doesn't understand that Islam is a
religion of peace right because they're
their version to subscribe to by 15
people is a religious right and you know
so it's like on Twitter what do you say
I think if one of these guys I said well
just let me know when the Sunnis stop
blowing up your mosques and hunting you
to the ends of the earth and then will
you that might have something to talk
about yeah the short answer to all this
is spend less time on Twitter yeah well
that is any of many many of the
mycological and social yeah okay
to move on to some of the signs up a
quick last two things on Carnival just
related to Hillary and this whole email
thing I wouldn't have to get into the
specifics of that but just from the pure
moral perspective you know basically the
Attorney General said she didn't
maliciously do anything but in effect he
was saying she's sort of an idiot and
doesn't really understand how any of
this stuff works I did things that's
sort of the most generous way to present
it I think because there's a lot of
evidence that she did kind of know about
some of this stuff and whatever so
without the specifics of that what do
you think about the morality of doing
something of not being held a count for
let's say she didn't do it maliciously
right that she's not being held
accountable of her actions if she had
done it maliciously it would have shown
that she tacitly knew what she was doing
and whatever and then you'd have a clear
answer the answer that they gave was she
didn't really know what she was doing
and she still did it that in a weird way
seems more dangerous to me do you do you
think that's fair to say
yeah I just don't think it's a danger
that scales to the presidency I think
it's yeah my my intuitive picture of
what I think happened there I think is
very likely right and it's just it's
annoying but it's not a deal breaker and
it would it would look different to me
if the person who's likely to benefit
from her prosecution is not going to
ruin the world right right like you have
to keep your eye on the bigger problem
here which is so you're admitting that
it has a little to do with politics it
your feelings on this in this case have
to do with a little bit of the political
landscape that that's you had level two
Trump is so high okay even if there if
there were an alternative to Hillary I
wouldn't waste a moment supporting
Hillary I mean I I really it really is a
lesser of two evils case to make for
Hillary okay even given the fact that I
think as I said probably 90% of the
policies that she actually would want to
enact would be policies
I would support so she's in I think
there's no question she's smart I think
there's no question she's well-informed
I think she's she is extraordinarily
well qualified given the sorts of people
who
run for the presidency and I don't think
she's going to destroy the world I think
she's going to be very centrist and
level-headed in almost every respect and
so like a is she if you just put her in
the Oval Office I don't I think just
that's a given certainly given the
alternative ethnics extraordinarily
positive outcome right and but it's
astonishing that in a nation of 300
million people we both didn't have 50
candidates who were obviously more
impressive than she is
yeah into both of both intellectually
and occupationally and ethically right I
mean just is like the fact that you we
don't have a dozen candidates each more
impressive than the next none of whom
has a scandal in his or her past none of
whom is an obvious liar right
it's just that it's amazing that that's
the that we don't have a system that
reliably promotes you know quality
people like that yeah so that's just the
ultimate condemnation of our system
right because if there was someone who
was really bright and had a real moral
Center why would you ever want to run
for president why would you ever want to
put yourself in that position and have
to do it seems to me that the Trump
thing is that he decided it's that it's
not that he has these specific plans
that anyone cares about but he decided
I'm going to win and he keeps reminding
everyone that he's the winner and I
think for a long time people have felt
that they're not winners here and now
he's just got this this sort of engine
of winning and that and sadly he didn't
have anyone on that side 17 of them he
didn't have one out of those 16 people
yeah to say I'm smart and I have a moral
Center so he just took them down one at
a time no that was incredible to watch I
was certainly surprised by that I
remember saying about a a year ago that
there's no way we're going to be talking
about Trump next fall and and obviously
many people were in that boat but but
just to answer your question about the
email thing I think probably
she's surrounded by people who none of
whom are actual techies right so like
they didn't understand the implications
of having it all on their server using
their own BlackBerry's and they don't
understand you understand that you're in
a Starbucks and you use Starbucks Wi-Fi
if people can just hack all your stuff
right right what percentage of Americans
understand the implications of just
getting on a free wireless network it
may be it's probably less than 10% and
Hillary Clinton may be one of them right
so zoetic she's not a there's no one
from the Genius Bar is in her inner
circle right which is a problem but I
don't think that's a problem that's
going to be true of we once she's
president so and yeah I'm sure she
wanted to keep it on her server for all
of the self-serving and and pair both
paranoid and understandably paranoid
reasons that you'd expect I mean she's
just she wants she wants to keep her
email to herself and she doesn't want to
have to have 15 different devices and
she she's probably worried about being
hacked and didn't realize that she
exposed herself to that more rather than
less by you know keeping it in your
house and so but it's just it's it's
dumb but it's not lets default on
America's debt
right which is which is so dumb and so
it just suggests such a terrifying lack
of awareness for the limits of his
knowledge of anything
I mean irrelevant to governing a
superpower that it's um you know who
knows what stupid decisions are possible
you nobody down that path